ah je ne trouve pas ce que cherche je ne
trouve pas ce que je cherche bélier
taureau gémeaux cancer lion vierge
balance scorpion sagittaire mais y'a
rien concernant les chaudes qui c'est
très ennuyeux car nous avons reçu une
lettre de madame meunier rue
doudeauville bonjour madame meunier dans
le xviiie au début de l'année tous les
mages voyante heuzé pythie sûrement
savait que les pythies est à des
personnages étranges qui avait toujours
la bouche pleine pas ce qu'en disait
l'appétit vient en mangeant
alors au début de l'année tous les mages
voyante et lecteurs d'avenir et pythie
nous on prédit ce qui allait arriver qui
allait arriver pythie a pity d'ailleurs
horoscope machin pourtant un doute
subsiste nulle part je n'ai vu une
allusion aux shadoks
et oui bien sûr alors que va-t-il
arriver aux shadoks
nous sommes allés chez des voyants qui
ont entouré d'animaux mystique nous sont
renseignés sur l'avenir des chapeaux en
émoi
dis moi quel est mon riche et fort leur
amour va couler je le revois énormément
de réussite une continuation très
heureuse et ils seront infiniment plus
appréciés dans l'avenir que par le passé
certainement
c'est obligatoire à mon avis c'était
l'émission philosophique
je trouve que c'est vraiment une
philosophie de la vie
c'est par certains côtés une ressemble
énormément quand on voit des gens c'est
will you still et au vietnam est discuté
à paris si la table de conférence de
presse va être de conférence de paix
doit être ronde blonde carré ou autres
formes évidemment on ne peut se trouver
ensemble ils iront loin ils iront de
l'avant
c'est dans leur esprit absolue des
shadoks nous en serons tous les jours
les mois
dis-moi dalmon du mois je les vois sous
le signe des poissons
heureusement n'est ce pas changé nous là
n'est pas la question mais enfin je
trouve que le signe du poisson convient
très bien de sa tâche
ici en partie à fait de votre avis même
quand aussi quoique et herman cain pas
tellement d'astrologie mais je suis
optimiste pour les hommes comme pour les
shadoks
et bien moi j'en ai vu proches auraient
ensuite misé sur parce que ma vie la vie
que nous disons à l'heure actuelle
pleine rue et en se maintenant c'est
c'est la période de chaleur et vous vous
considérez les génois exactement comme
mais ça vote
j'en suis certaine c'est comme si vous
voyez vous comme il n'y a plus rien de
ces lieux sûrs que je trouve quand même
on devrait inventer inventé sur le champ
je pense qu'on pourrait dire faire du
shadow schisme
ce serait quelque chose de tout à fait
valable cela fait oublier par là deux
choses de la vie
une pluie de guerre du coleader
révolution de brave et tout ce qui s'en
suit alors en amour les shabab fait
oublier tout le monde est à
l'harmonieuse leurs sous-vêtements et
vie
je ne suis absolument pas inquiets sur
leur avenir
alors vous qui ne pas le fonds central